I mean,
what happened as far as I can understand it,
some financial wizards figured out that by bundling mortgages together,
you could calculate their average riskiness and then you could discount them
according to that riskiness and then you could sell them as high grade
investments.
And the regulatory agencies went along with that.
And that's partly because they're generally staffed by people who aren't as
smart as the people who were manipulating the monetary system for obvious
reasons.
And it was brilliant.
It makes sense that if you take a bunch of risky investments that you can and
you can calculate the risk and discounted,
then you stabilize.
It gets brilliant.
Except for one thing,
they didn't calculate the fact that everything could collapse it once.
Now what happened was when they transformed these risky investments into stable
investments,
they got really valuable.
And so it was worthwhile for the banks to give mortgages to everybody that could
possibly process.
And that's where the crookedness started.
Dis CPM,
you know,
they thought,
well,
it doesn't matter how risky be mortgage is because we'll average that out
anyways and we're going to make money on that.
On the trash.
I think they were called brilliant,
except for the one thing that no one expected,
which was that the whole bloody market could collapse at once.
So,
you know,
you can think,
well,
it's obvious in retrospect,
no,
no obvious,
you know,
like the American housing market value peaked way below what the Japanese
housing market had peaked out.
You know,
after you decades before it was nothing like it.
Jada,
Japanese real estate market got inflated away past the American.
So now one,
you don't know where the talk is.
So,
and the,
you know,
the crookedness was
people's failure to play by standard rules of risk evaluation.
But even that's complicated because they thought,
well,
maybe these rules don't apply anymore.
And that's what the guys who were making these bundled investments we're trying
to do.
They were trying to make the old rules not apply anymore by eradicating the risk
didn't work.
Was it crooked?
Probably.
It's not so obvious though.